[Music]
blow away hundreds of shows on TV one
thing I find helpful when I watching
television is that little info button on
the cable remote brings up the screen
tells you what you need to know about
the show you're watching I thought we'd
take a look at some info button results
right now and a piece would like to call
what the hell am i watching Jane the
Virgin and I hit the button no spoilers
but let's say that after tonight's
episode we need a new titles I don't
even know what this is about it's about
a girl who's a virgin but she gets
pretty go to the doctor the doctor is
confused gives her sperm it was the
truth someone else what yes what are you
talking about you're confused
gynecologist gets her which one is in
which room what and go it's awful mm-hmm
so you're the one that needs sperm and
and bright sperms and room a Jane the
virgins and room B it's like when the
three was in with the sperm well I'm so
distracted by some bullsh then she goes
into the other room and there's that's a
primitive minute you're the old lady who
was supposed to get the sperm that so
that's the premise of the whole show and
then so it's like when the Three Stooges
when Moe is cooking yes and he reaches
back for the hot sauce right and his
hand goes near the hot sauce but then
drift slowly right and there's a thing
that says black igloo right and he takes
the glue and puts it in the cake and
then later there with the high-society
bear with me kids and they're all
chomping away and then I can't move
their lips right and it's the late 30s
so everyone's laughing right because the
depressions on Jesus Christ they can't
believe that yeah what's that do you
guys like that show you can say don't
it's a good show right put the camera on
them let's get a record of this no but
it's it a good show so once you get past
the it's about a sociopath who runs a
gynecology lab you're it's okay all
right
Yello
well it's the producer of Jane the
Virgin what they want they say it's a
very good show oh wow yeah they say once
you get past the premise it's a great
show
where did they they saw the feed here
darling to feed our feed goes out to all
of the shows oh wow
wish I had known I would have been
working harder hi
I got Friday's off
[Music]
you